everybody I am Dwayne Johnson and this
is what it takes for support Bible not
only did I play for a college football
team at that time I played for the best
college football team in the country
University of Miami
the Hurricanes we were national
champions and the number one goal was to
play in the NFL the National Football
League
pro football and that did not happen for
me and I it was that was hard it was
hard that was a hard kick in the gut
because I'd worked for years and years
and years to make it to the NFL I didn't
my friends around me were making it and
they were becoming millionaires and
buying their parents houses all the
dreams that we all had and they were
living the dreams that we had and I was
not I was actually living a nightmare I
fell into depression at that time
and what it took to get out of that was
time and self empathy like you know
being good to myself and recognizing
that life goes on and this was not the
path for me as much as I wanted it to be
the path as much as I felt like I was
doing everything I could to make sure
that that happened just didn't happen
and it wasn't for me and that wasn't the
life of the path for me and then I
picked myself back up and put in the
work with my own two hands and created
another path oh wow
so what is happening in this photo is
this was the other path that I felt was
for me and this is my debut in the WWE
and not only was it my debut my very
first match in the WWE but I was
debuting at one of their major
pay-per-view of the year so you talked
about baptism by fire this was me as
Rocky Maivia and Rocky Maivia was a name
that honored both my grandfather and my
father both who are WWE legends and Hall
of Famers and that is also me with a
terrible [ __ ] haircut what it took to
become the number one wrestler in the
company and arguably the number one
wrestler in the world was a lot of hard
work a lot of perseverance a lot of
focus and a lot of
continuous context and what I mean by
that is it just required me at that time
I was flying by the seat of my pants I
became the number one wrestler in the
WWE by the time I was 26 or 27 years old
which was an incredible amount of
pressure and responsibility but what I
mean by constant context is I constantly
had to check myself and make sure that I
was approaching everything at that time
knowing that as hard as wrestling is
physically and as demanding as it is
physically and emotionally mentally it's
still fiction and when I lose letting
other guys beat me and when I'm winning
I'm really not beating anyone and
they're letting me beat them and that's
the kind of context that you have to
keep in your mind because otherwise in
that water pro wrestling the ego can
really go out of control and you lose
contacts you lose perspective and then
you don't become the biggest draw the
company has ever seen so what it takes
to become the how do I want to say this
I see alright so well looking at this
picture what it takes to become a we'll
just say a bankable actor you guys could
say big as movie's over the world it it
takes again hard work and it takes
perseverance and again it just takes
context and it takes perspective
especially when you get into this world
of Hollywood in the business of
Hollywood because it is so demanding and
it's incredibly difficult yes being in
the ring is incredibly difficult but the
scope of audience and world that you now
entertain and are responsible for in
movies
global and this is why it requires a
consistent and very constant daily hard
work and also very very important is
trust your gut and trust your instincts
on what the audience will really enjoy
and love and that's really the most
important thing Oh God
[Music]
yeah
so the first time I saw this photo I was
in Calgary Alberta Canada and it was
about five o'clock in the morning and I
was getting ready to go to the gym
before I headed to the set of shooting
Jumanji
and I woke up to this photo seeing this
photo for the very first time and there
at this point of my life there are very
few times in my life where I'm
completely blown back on my ass when I
see something and completely moved maybe
even a little emotional but when I saw
this it was just it was a reflection of
again hard work and but also just this
bigger idea that I never in my life
would have ever imagined to be on the
cover of Time magazine is you know
pretty influential guy
so I would say the most important things
that made this whole thing happen from
where I started - this right here would
be two things it would be hard work and
always putting the audience first and
how important that is I did that in
wrestling even when I was wrestling in
front of 50 people in barns and flea
markets and used car dealerships did
that in movies and certainly now cover
Time magazine is crazy but certainly do
that now is work hard and always always
always put the audience first because
ultimately at the end of the day it's
the audience that will drive the entire
journey because it's always about them
I'm Dwayne Johnson and this is what it
takes
you